Você já viu aqueles bolos e docinhos com
glitter brilhando? Pois é. Olha só esse
alerta da Anvisa que acabou de sair. A
Anvisa chamou atenção por um problema
sério. Tem gente usando glitter feito de
plástico, tal do PPP ou PP micronizado
para decorar alimentos de festa
infantis. O detalhe é que esse produto
não é comestível, ele é atóxico, sim,
mas é o mesmo material usado em
embalagens plásticas. E claro, ninguém
come embalagem, né? pelo menos não
voluntariamente. Então, o caso veio à
tona depois que o influenciador mostrou
a embalagem de um glitter alimentício,
que na verdade tinha esse plástico na
composição. E o risco é real,
principalmente para crianças. Já temos
corantes artificiais que mesmo sendo
liberados são polêmicos e proibidos em
outros países. Agora imagina ingerir
glitter de plástico. Então fica o
recado. Leia sempre o rótulo. Se você
trabalha com festas ou é pai e mãe
preparando aniversário do seu filho,
pergunte o que está sendo usado nos
doces e bolos. Às vezes, um simples
brilho pode esconder um grande perigo.